[Música]
y en directo a hoy nos vamos a esta
ciudad de Guatemala para hablar con
nuestro corresponsal para Centroamérica
Andrés Suárez Jaramillo con el vamos a
ahondar en la previa las elecciones
presidenciales de este próximo domingo
para la que los 22 candidatos que
concurren han empezado Perdón han
empezado ya a cerrar campaña este mismo
jueves el viernes es la fecha límite
para estos cierres la última encuesta
publicada este mismo jueves por el
diario Prensa libre ubica la
conservadora y ex primera dama Sandra
Torres en cabeza Andrés recta final de
esta campaña presidencial Cómo se ha
vivido y Qué ambiente hay entre los
guatemaltecos
Rodrigo muy buenas noches Hay un
ambiente de deslegitimidad de Falta de
confianza Guatemala atraviesa una crisis
de no tener de que sus instituciones no
se sientan legítimas hemos hablado con
muchas personas en las calles y nos
dicen más de lo mismo si ya todo está
arreglado para que votar Lo cierto es
que pues desde organismos
internacionales se ha denunciado de un
presunto anticipado fraude un fraude
electoral anticipado porque aunque no
Hemos llegado a la cita del domingo de
las votaciones si ya han habido movidas
como la exclusión de tres candidatos que
podrían llegar a amenazar el
establecimiento el denominado pacto de
corruptos aquí en Guatemala Entonces ya
se encuentran en el país para vigilar y
supervisar estos comicios del domingo
las misiones de observadores tanto de la
Unión Europea como de la oea la
organización de los Estados Americanos
para supervisar que no vaya a haber
ningún fraude le preguntamos al tribunal
supremo electoral sobre este tema y nos
dijo que no hay posibilidad de que esto
llegue a ocurrir porque Quienes cuentan
los votos quienes registran las
papeletas son los propios ciudadanos y
bueno Andrés avanzaba antes que la
última encuesta da a Sandra Torres como
favorita pero con casi toda probabilidad
habrá una segunda vuelta quién es ella
cuéntanos y quién podría ser su rival en
balotaje
bueno Sandra Torres es una de las
políticas de más larga trayectoria aquí
en Guatemala ella fue primera dama de la
nación en la presidencia de Álvaro Colón
del 2008 al 2011 luego se divorció de él
para poderse postular como presidenta y
estuvo ya en dos candidaturas anteriores
donde también pasó a segunda vuelta
perdió contra Jaime Morales en el 2015 y
luego contra Alejandro yamatei en el
2019 se dice que ella carga mucho
antiboto aquí en Guatemala sin embargo
Sí con la última encuesta la de hoy ella
tiene 21 puntos pasaría a segunda vuelta
sin problema y la pregunta es con quién
se va a enfrentar Sí con edmoth mulet
que tiene 13 puntos en esta en esta
encuesta estaría de segundo o si con
Suri Ríos la hija del dictador de
Guatemala Efraín Ríos montt quien tiene
nueve entre ellos dos sur y ríos pues se
juega la segunda plaza para pasar a
segunda vuelta aquí en Guatemala